la vuelta a casa más amarga más de 4000
venezolanos han regresado a su país
desde Panamá en las últimas semanas esto
Gracias a donaciones de Iglesias y
particulares ya que la repatriación
exigía que los migrantes debían
costearse el boleto aéreo pero no todos
lo han conseguido no no dicen que no hay
vuelo humanitario que busque manera de
conseguir dinero o un familiar que esté
afuera que nos mande digo llega hasta
México Y me tuve que volver acá y acá me
llevo aproximadamente ya casi más de 20
días llega el refugio y bueno ha sido
bastante duro más al norte en México los
migrantes no quieren volver en Matamoros
fronterizo con Tejas las autoridades
desmontaron Un campamento con cientos de
personas la mayoría venezolanos y
haitianos la sociedad civil exigen más
ayuda desgraciadamente estamos
recibiendo un flujo alto de migrantes y
que pues como siempre Matamoros no está
preparado para una migración de esta
naturaleza nos hace falta de todo
albergues de ropa agua comida para ellos
el Limbo continúa entre los que regresan
y los que no desisten en conseguir su
sueño esto pese al acuerdo al que
llegaron a Estados Unidos y México por
el que todos los migrantes que pasen la
frontera terrestre serán devueltos a
territorio mexicano y no a sus países de
origen a cambio Estados Unidos otorgará
24.000 visas solo a quienes ingresen por
vía aérea